i uh have the rest of the multiple
personality video that we were watching
yesterday oh yeah let's watch him
you wanna do that okay yeah and without
question that guy was great so uh we
only got through some of it and uh just
a
quick little update for those that may
have missed it yesterday first off
where the [ __ ] were you and also
secondly right we're
have we confirmed that that's not susan
wojcicki we don't know
we have not confirmed but this is one of
the dudes from smosh which apparently
you're supposed to know where you're a
loser
um oh so he is from some things one of
the
the guy interviewing him is one of the
dudes from the smosh youtube channel
smosh is a huge youtube channel
apparently and people were
saying calling us stupid for not knowing
who they were but i mean i don't know
man i only watch my things on youtube
and maybe we are dumb
25 million subscribers smosh has
uh i guess they've been around a long
time
whatever but i'm looking at their
wikipedia and i'm looking
at like their
sort of whatever their sphere of like
things that they're interested in
of course i never heard of these guys
it's literally just all like
i don't know so uh these were like kid
youtubers a while back you know we
missed that boat sorry
so the dude from smosh has been
interviewing people that have multiple
personality disorders or
as it's called now identity disorder
or as i call it a [ __ ] lie and
he's going through different youtubers
that have it and they're explaining him
how they got it and
so we only got up to four minutes of
this video it's a long video so uh let's
keep doing it here we go
seven years i have 16 there's 17 of us
total ranging from age four
to eternal eternal eternal she's really
because we're all making this all up as
we go
that is the face of a [ __ ] raving
lunatic
yeah that is a raving lunatic
[Music]
she's really really cool well you should
go her frequently
um she fronts she looks like the kind of
woman
who doesn't like that you left your
garbage cans out
one extra day so she literally calls the
police
you know what i mean she's one of those
and when the police show up they're
upset they're like little
man full of garbage i don't want to
[ __ ] all right
i was actually on my lunch break and
there were no other deputies available
and i had to come to this so just do man
just do me a favor
do me a solid and you're like yeah i'll
do that yeah man sorry man but
but it's all right fine i'll do it right
but it's not because she told me to and
it's like that's fine man
i don't care she's doing me can you do
it for me thanks thank you
and then and then he gives you a card
leave you get a speeding ticket just
here give him this
this woman calls me seven times a week
she calls the station
seven times a week somebody parked four
inches away from the curb last week
she called us three times we actually
had a triple homicide we were
investigating
we had to pull a detective off of that
they don't call me the freeze frame kit
for nothing
she actually called us because she
thought that maybe some kids were
swimming in her pool
when she was sleeping at night and they
broke into her yard so we pulled
two detectives off a triple homicide so
we could dust her pool for prince
this is the kind of woman i'm talking
about but don't worry her
attorney is a cat no i'm not a cat
i'm just okay get the damn filter off
all right uh let's continue here
occasionally she's the caretaker so she
takes care of the littles in her heads
and then occasionally oh littles i i've
learned what this is
littles are some of their alters are
children they'll come out
okay but this is an easy fix right okay
off to the looney pin you go ready
can we start calling it the looney bin
again i love that we put you in the
loony bin and hear me out on this right
if we brought back loony bins do you
know how many of these attention seeking
would go 180 and go no no no i'm cured
i'm i don't have it anymore
i'm fine we need and when i say bring
back looney i don't even mean like the
the stereotypical like the hospitals
where they give you drugs and stuff i'm
talking one of those asylums like from
boardwalk empire
that they put jillian darmody in
which one of her alts is chrissy mayer
do we know all of them oh you're right
me if i'm not doing so well um so she
she kind of fronts in the sidelines and
behind the scenes more
first off do you prefer to be referred
to as
a single or plural well it depends who
you're talking to if you're talking
about
you're not that pretty or interesting
not for this
anybody's going to want to deal with
this you know what i mean i mean you're
probably good for a quick
pump but like well which one which 30
which one 37's are first
kyle i'm all for kyle too dude call [ __ ]
you like a dude
let's [ __ ] bro kyle's a top
about me as in me the person sat in
front of you talking to you
with my personality then it's me one
person as nin
but if i was like can you do it on
command like rich little used to do
impressions you think
can you do that i think you would go a
little something like this
[Laughter]
was that your bill cosby because that
was your that was the bill cosby yeah
that was pretty good and then there's
the
there's the de niro yeah you just do the
[ __ ] underbite thing yeah that's not
like
[ __ ] not rich little lady
a coke on so there was more than one
person essentially in the driving seat
then it would be we i know i've seen
what are you [ __ ] voltron
in the driving seat are you serious
oh i know i've said this before and i'll
probably say it a hundred more
times and watch these videos but you
know you got three books in there
right 78 personalities among them and
not one interesting one
yep like what are the odds that you have
27 personalities and not
and they're all boring [ __ ] and
they're all youtubers
yes they just look weird boring
youtubing
i think that she should uh that youtube
finish the sentence
oh i apologize no i was joking i said oh
did i talk over you you said i think she
should and i'm like can i finish this
no please don't i thought you were still
saying something i was like oh my bad
i thought i was [ __ ] disassociating
for a second i'm like did something
happen
and yes or no i think she should do that
too but
i think i think that um
that they should be allowed on youtube
but with one caveat
every one of our personalities has to
have their own channel
that's so you can't have one channel
your subs have to be spread across
37 different youtube channels more than
one person
how might a normal day be different for
you
you want ah i can't i know this one's
really
it's a rough one this one's a really
this one's a rough one
what's that answer this question yeah so
this is this you know what he looks like
if she looks like her they look like the
the newer snl cast member the one with
the curly hair the skinny one
you know what i'm talking about i forget
his name someone will know but that's
what he
she they look like this person
so it was like a combination of ali and
eliza talking before oh okay
um we can kind of blend hold on hold on
so alts can blend
can can be more than one i'm gonna guys
i gotta
i figured i i didn't know royce was so
behind on this so i'm gonna i'm gonna
school him a little bit here
please see royce um when
everything you're doing is totally made
up ah
you can pretty much do whatever you want
see this isn't a mental illness this is
just a
really really bad improv exercise i got
it
yes and yeah that's all it is it's just
a bad
ucb uh exercise so it's like sometimes
they just blend together and then they
become dragons and you're like that's
weird cool weird i think and
sometimes so when we first came into
what we would call co-consciousness
and what i would call disgusting yeah
and that's i'm telling you right now if
you if you could bring back
involuntary admission to mental health
hospitals
these people would go no no no i'm cured
i'm fine i'm fine i'm coming five no i
was kidding
i'll go to work i'll go to work i'll go
to work
which is the shared experience of kind
of being able to talk to each other
a lot of people don't have that and
they're basically like
coordinating in the dark with someone
who's not there when they're there
and so like uh you might be doing
something and then
come back and it's three days or three
weeks later what do you do
i have a feeling you don't do much well
just gotta get to the dilation station
on time
i have i'm sure this is not one of those
that even committed that fire
yeah you're right you know this is just
you you probably lay around smoke pot
all day and play nintendo switch
when we're doing something like what
like what it like
the whole basis of this multiple
personality [ __ ] is that
you know deep down when you're alone
with your thoughts that you don't
do anything that you're just gonna
be a [ __ ] you're gonna be bones in a
box like the rest of us someday
and that that dread that creeps in
makes you feel like okay i have to be
something super special
i can't just be another normie
[ __ ] so you've decided you're
multiple people living in a celestial be
like it's it's nonsense you just don't
want to face the fact that
you're a nobody who will accomplish
nothing and you'll die
and your life has been lived and all
kinds of stuff is happening i have a
friend who would be heading one place
and then someone would switch this back
home
and then they'd switch and head back and
forth and it'd take like four hours
to get out of that so they shouldn't be
driving if they
see this is the thing they want to have
their [ __ ] cake and eat it too
right if you want to say you have this
okay fine you have this then you
shouldn't be allowed to drive
no because if you really can't control
who you are
you should never be behind the wheel of
a car ever
yeah like i honestly there have been
times that i'm sure you've had this too
i've had legitimate times where i need
to be somewhere or something
and my anxiety is so bad that i don't
want to get behind the wheel of a car
because i am putting people in danger
like i'm better off driving with
with alcohol in me than i am driving if
i can
feel a panic attack coming on if i can
get a xanax
then i can take like a half a xanax and
then i drive and i'm fine
but like like roy said if you feel like
this thing is gonna pop up while you're
driving you're putting people into you
shouldn't be allowed
to drive a car you should have some
self-awareness and go
yeah i can't like drive i'll take an
uber or something because i might pass
out while i'm behind the wheel and i
don't want to do that
until the same person came back and was
like no we're actually going here
and what they learned to do is to text
uh their
themselves or leave notes on their
iphone yeah and
read those and so it's kind of when you
come to the front you feel disoriented
yeah you can read those notes almost
like having amnesia and leaving notes
yeah
it's it's called dissociative amnesia
it's like it's like it's like memento
except i [ __ ] at least
understood memento yeah i don't know
what this is
basically the term for that i was in the
bath i just switched i was in the bath
i was doing a video for my only fans
she's british
she's like i was taking my monthly bath
out so i had no memory of what happened
before i didn't remember getting in the
bath because it wasn't me
yeah with my how do you travel alone how
because this is shot in america
how did you fly to the states i couldn't
remember anything right i was in the
bath
and then all of a sudden i come to you
and i've got a back massager in me [ __ ]
and i'm just laying there like what
happened
just they called it the stranger and
then they were like oh you was making
cummies and i said are you sure in it
and then we was like oh and then we went
got some indian food
because that's the only thing we've got
here
i alter kyle he's my primary protector
and
he'd apparently decide let me tell you
something if kyle's a dude
i'll knock that [ __ ] out i ain't
worried about kyle
you're protecting [ __ ] are you allowed
to beat up
like dudes you're the dude i mean i'll
look i'll play your game if you want but
then you're a dude
i did that he wanted a snack while he
was in the bar and there was just this
half-eaten banana
on like the shampoo holder you're lying
i was like what why that's disgusting
we let people do this like
why why you know i was watching this
clip of patrice last night when he was
just talking
about how like you know brutal honesty
is such a shitty term because
honesty should be good the truth should
be good
the truth should be what we seek right
but nobody wants to be honest anymore
and it's like
no everyone's just going to indulge this
dopey [ __ ]
instead of just being like [ __ ] stop
making this stuff up
stop it just realize that you are
in a bathroom with a half-eaten banana
it was pretty beautifully presented
actually how do you feel about the
the different labels in terms of
personality
alt attention [ __ ] liars
characters identities i want
like this i want to be like this [ __ ]
earring flock of seagulls here
i want to be like i want to get the
guests he gets so i can go like
so like i'm i'm just curious like what's
it like being a [ __ ]
while the same inspirational music's
playing piano on the same set
by the way same everything just going
like what is that
please tell me and then do like a jiminy
click what's it like
to be and go
i'm shifting around on my chair
and just in the background it's just
this
[Music]
they're telling me what's with your
fake british accent
[Music]
i hear you're from cleveland is that
true
he's [ __ ] tucking his gut in and
pulling the cards out
god what was his wife's name i forgot he
always said
jiminy was fantastic you know what's
weird i'll be the first to admit i
didn't get it
when it came when i was younger like i
just didn't understand it
but it's one of those things you watch
later when you're older and you're like
why didn't i like this when i was
younger this is brilliant it's [ __ ]
brilliant
there are a lot of people who don't like
the term
personality because i doubt because i
don't have
god damn it we're butt heads we butted
heads on that one
i've had to invent a bunch of fantastic
stories
to be interesting
a lot of people think of personality
they think of like how you act in a
certain situation
so some people when i told them about
did
in its most basic terms it said like i
have a completely different personality
when i'm at work
and then i come home and i'm a different
person and it's like i completely
understand what you're saying
yeah but uh it's kind of different when
it comes to did so some people feel that
the term personality isn't quite
encompassing or serious enough i don't
mind the time personality but
this [ __ ] smosh [ __ ]
oh but this is what
but this is what we're becoming
culturally is just people
telling you obvious nonsense while you
go wow
that's cool we just indulge everybody
indulges each other too much there's no
more honesty left honesty is
dead it's a dead concept
the the term that's generally used in
the community and the scientific
kind of side of things is alters because
it stands for alternate state of
identity
you're making up things i get it you're
making up i got it i trust me i get it
like when they talk about this [ __ ]
right it's like when you hear people
talk about like
mormonism and you're like
so okay so here's the thing like i when
i die like i get my own planet right
it's really cool like dude and you know
like up until like the 70s we didn't
even let black people
in which was kind of really cool native
americans are actually demons so the
native americans are demon people
and when we came to america jesus was a
farmer sir i don't mean to cut you off
this the line is starting to get pretty
long behind you oh sorry do you want to
ring up those lucky charms
and that [ __ ] pack of cools
[Laughter]
did you want to move this along please
hey bring them young
there's people that want to buy their
slurpees but it's like they and people
just go
wow yeah that's great you get your own
planet
or like scientology and then a bunch of
the bad souls
were doomed and they put them in a
volcano and then used dc tens to drop
nukes on the soles of the bit and you're
like
i get it but you have to take the eye
test if you want the license
so sir you gotta we gotta move along put
your face on the thing
sir if you're not gonna okay you know
what c4
[Laughter]
get out of here beat it and i kind of
felt myself
as a consciousness retreat to the back
of my own mind
so i was watching everything from behind
and there was just
nothing there in 2012
yeah so in 2012 uh jim henson did my
voice until he passed away
whatever alta's kermit defrog i i
i if if i could have any super power in
the world
it would be to just shatter these
people's delusions
and make them live in the horrendous
pain of self-awareness
for just a moment if i could do that if
i could have just one
professor x ability it would be the
ability to make you go
oh my god i really am nothing and i'm
going to die alone and oh my god i want
i
if i could make these people spiral with
my mind i would
the fact that they live in this coddled
little universe and these
[ __ ] youtubers just can go yeah wow
and they can spread
dangerous medical disinformation while
we get kicked off of youtube for making
gay jokes with our friends
yeah that's well obviously what we're
doing is more dangerous to society than
people that think they're 30 people and
are driving
royce i barely leave the house yeah well
okay
these people are driving in complete few
extents i would say
that i'm still less of a threat to the
community than they are
i wish i had a bunch of altar so maybe
one of them could understand what the
[ __ ] donnie darko was about
yes because honestly like [ __ ] one of
them
royce is gonna have one personality and
that's his only defining characteristic
is that he understood donnie
yeah i know what the rabbit was about
and the [ __ ] engine that fell off the
plane it's a very
existential film and it's sort of done
in a style that's
like okay i would hate that personality
waste of a personality what a waste of a
movie
shut up shut up
that same personality is just royce
going you ever listen to fear factors
yes
oh [ __ ] christ that sucks
this guy's terrible that personality is
the one that goes to parties but
only plays like the first few chords of
a song would never place the whole song
and you want to smash the guitar with
their [ __ ] heads
dude this personality sucks can i have
the original can i have gay royce
hey wait a second
can i have the cool gay guy i'd do the
show with back
oh [ __ ] man this is so we just switched
right there really
is ally talking but then like ali pulled
away because this is eliza i was
boring everybody and i thought i'd
switch because it's my only trick
just to switch and thought i was the
only one
um so yeah i thought i was
a boy and so well it's probably the
penis
i would assume it was the [ __ ] and balls
by the way we could agree this piece of
[ __ ] is the most low effort terrible one
out of all of them
yeah like at least the [ __ ] chick
like does a little like whoa
hang on oh boy i'm getting up
oh boy i'm switching and then she makes
the transformer sound
wait and then she's like oh now i'm a
dude
this one just goes yeah you know it's
like this one actually
doesn't change the voice the the cadence
anything about how they talk and then
just finishes the sentence
and then they're like oh i switched
there you didn't catch it ah you didn't
catch it
at least [ __ ] nin tries to do the
[ __ ] the whole like
uh the kali moth switch but you know
she's just switching like on the [ __ ]
fly by the way can i just point out that
this guy who probably pretends to be
really supportive and nice and
he's not exploitive at all if you notice
he's only having the
mildly attractive girl and the absolute
there's been
absolutely no emphasis on
the other one oh gummy mcgee because
she's boring and he knows it's not good
content yeah he doesn't actually give a
[ __ ] about these people
i thought i was one person pretty
standard
like you are expectations right you're
just one
terrible mediocre broken person
like weird triggering confrontation with
a stranger
she looks like she's about to d to
disassociate to ben shapiro
look she kind of looks like ben man she
really does he
they i don't know whatever are it's they
them
okay okay facts first off all of my
personalities
show gold okay bowling branch sheets are
great for all my 37 alts do you have uh
out of your 37 alts is any of them not a
zionist
uh all my alts can go to israel anytime
they want for free oh nice
i get to go anytime i want to go free
the american taxpayer place right now
free for me sure basically what i
understand is that i had a
whole system of covering up all of this
a whole like strategy and everything but
i was so busy dealing with
family member with cancer personal life
stress housing stress
and then yeah life man you're dealing
with lady you're dealing with stuff that
is life it's human it sucks these things
[ __ ] suck and life is brutal
sometimes
but that doesn't mean you get to [ __ ]
pretend to be the entire [ __ ]
pittsburgh steelers when you're bored
you know what i love
these people too they always pretend
they had this deep trauma but then when
you asked about it
they were in like a mild fender bender
like 10 years ago and you're like that's
not a
deep trauma like people that have been
to wars people that have been
yeah people that have real drugs they're
people that have been there's prisoners
of war that don't act like you
if you have ptsd you're allowed a couple
things you're allowed to thank you for
your service and being afraid of
fireworks yeah and that
will allow you those things oh and by
the way don't think i'm not gonna do
fireworks because i'm still doing them
but i'm gonna feel bad about it i'm just
gonna be aware of your
thing okay
this sudden trigger it crumbled yeah and
there was
i'm not allowed to celebrate with
fireworks because you got hyped up from
some commercial you saw right after 9
11. yes well and now my [ __ ] holiday
weekend's ruined i don't think so pal
well to be fair with maureen fighting a
lava dragon or something
so you have to go [ __ ] it is that the
one in the dress blues with the sword
that's the one that's the one that would
be the one shoulda went into battle with
sword brad
who would have been badass or you could
join the
marines the air force yes it doesn't
matter
ally and z how did you feel once you
realized
yeah that i wasn't the only one here
yeah um
so the first feeling was actually
overwhelming love and joy
you think we're gonna see the other one
that's you're right dude look
i'm i'm skipping through it and it's all
nin in the
oh they tell me their names oh really
and i have no idea where they come up
with some of them
because in your brain you come up with
them
i'm assuming looking at you they're
mostly harry potter names
like this is not something i would have
ever done
like what where did that come from like
one of my altar's name is freedom
freedom yes do does that all know what
this i want to just say something you
know do you know what i can tell this
woman has heard
many many times in her life before
well i gotta hop off here yep but uh
yeah
you know keep on uh keep on trucking or
whatever
keep on keeping on i'll talk to you soon
all right this one
she you know what phrase this woman's
heard more than any other phrase in her
life
well i'm going to go ahead and let you
go yeah
click a lot of people always have
meetings they forgot they had to go to
when they're talking to her
another great phrase oh yeah oh yeah
right
[Music]
like i'll hit a good one occasionally on
night wave but i'll never beat royce's
freeze frame batting average they're
always ridiculous
oh [ __ ] never represent freedom in any
way i mean
her first name was paine and then she
switched it to freedom
i hate these people's first name
i have so much nothing but
hate and contempt in my heart for these
people
last name great last name ever first
name greatest
a very literal name it was for her
so some of my my protectors she needs to
go to one of these
very like i was saying the boardwalk
empire mental hospital
take your teeth out no that would not
even they were like literally cutting
like
organs out of them because they thought
that's what the bad was
they're just coming in with these huge
scars in their abdomen and going the
doctor got the evil out
yeah no protector but name is brad yes
the protector
his role is as a protector how come all
the protectors for these women are
always
male characters you notice that because
trust me if you were really to try to
start peeling back the
layers of the onion of the female
psychology you'd be there all [ __ ]
day
i mean like they they resent men
they hate men but deep deep down they're
still
they're still wired see women don't
necessarily
hate men women hate themselves
so women hate all of those
instincts that they all have that they
want a man
they want to have a man they want to be
protected they want to be
cared for they want to be cared about
right
they don't hate men they resent that
deep down they need a man
they hate that that's they hate
themselves they hate their own desire
for like a patriarchal force in their
life
so they rebel against it and that's why
you get these [ __ ]
the blue hair and they lose their
[ __ ] minds but
when when a subconscious thing like this
happens they're like my protectors the
man and it's like
yeah because you can't find a man
there's no way that the nin one that the
hot one can't get a dude though like
dudes will still [ __ ] i mean there's no
way the not this ah
yeah they will they'll [ __ ] her but
she's not keeping any guys
that girl's not keeping any men she
might get laid i mean i
i'd [ __ ] her but actually i probably
wouldn't with with all the context
but she probably also plays down all
that multiple personality [ __ ]
when she's out you know what i mean it's
probably guys that just [ __ ] hit it
and then realized they walked into all
mine
look at that hottie i'm sexy
well okay i think they're about to do
having an easy time as
uh folks with the id like i'm
dissociating now
and hold on she's dissociating now here
we go
which who's she going to be i'm saying
toucan sam what do you think
whoever it is i hope they drop a hard n
word right in the middle of this
can she disassociate to our bud dwyer
[Laughter]
i'm sorry my alternate is gassy
sorry my alternate thought it would be a
good idea to have both a bang energy
drink and then coffee with half and half
in it oh no
oh no it's there i didn't have it for my
heart oh i could smell it now
it's like one of those that makes it's
one of those farts that doesn't sound
like a fart it sounds like a floorboard
squeaking
like oh sorry let me know whenever
you're ready here she goes
yo what's up player you know be so great
right
name withheld
child altar
what is going on here
name withheld it's we it's not a real
person sir
oh my god dude you know it would be
honestly you know what would make me
really
like just fall in love with this chick
is if she took this like
this gimmick as far as she could until
one day she's on like
h3 or she's on like joe rogan and she's
talking and she's like oh no
i'm disassociating and then she does
this old gag again and then she just
sits there for like
two minutes staring straight ahead in
dead silence
and then just goes
i've been [ __ ] with you guys the
whole time this is you know i've been
[ __ ] like
you guys are so i'm not even british you
really fall for this i'm from pittsburgh
um really let me come on this show you
guys are oh my god dude you'll fall for
anything
jesus christ and she just i'd be like
okay you know what
yeah i'd be like dad's chick rules
that's the only way you can redeem
herself
i've been bullshitting you guys for two
years i got a [ __ ] youtube plaque and
everything
you guys are dumb uh and she's like i'm
starting and only fans i'm gonna stick
things in my [ __ ] haul and everybody's
like you know what this chick's all
right
nice i'm gonna be doing a video where i
let's out with belle delphi
uh miami milf says uh the names with
health because you can't dox a child bro
i'm i'm i'm i'm getting angry i
why dude getting angry what are you mad
about you know what i'm mad about
we're we're dying as a species and it's
because we're just
sitting here letting this kind of stuff
happen it's because we all sit around
and go
wow that's that's really interesting
instead of going [ __ ] you're full of
[ __ ] stop